in this video we'll talk about the
transcription factors transcription
factors are proteins involved in the
process of transcription
and it initiates the transcription
process and regulates gene expression so
it recruits RNA polymerase and modulate
expression of many protein codeine genes
now where does transcription Factor
binds there are specific set of
transcription factors that bind to the
promoted region of a gene and helps the
RNA polymerase to be recruited and
initiate the transcription process these
kind of transcription factors are known
as the general transcription Factor
they are binding to the promoter is
important for RNA polymerase recruitment
so they are the bare minimum to start
our transcription
so in vitro situation if you put these
generalized transcription Factor along
with polymerase transcription reaction
should happen
now along with that there are other set
of transcription factors which can bind
to regulatory elements such as an
enhancer
and interact with other proteins such as
mediators to bring out or to modulate
the rate of transcription it can
regulate how fast the transcription it
would be how efficient the transcription
it would be so these are known as
specialized transcription factors
now when we think about transcription we
have to imagine a 3D space inside the
nucleus of an eukaryotic cell there
would be genome
in a 3D organization and it's damn
complicated you could have an
organization like this and transcription
Factor has to navigate its way through
the particular promoter site or a
regulatory element and then give rise to
a gene transcription and all of this is
happening in a incredibly crowded
environment
so the question is uh how exactly this
is taking place inside the nucleus
in the nucleus the DNA would not be
alone so we cannot only think of a DNA
Centric image when we are thinking about
a transcription Factor binding to a
promoter we have to think about the
nucleosomes the beads on string
appearance of the chromatin in this case
transcription Factor would bind and RNA
polyvaries would move through the gene
body
and this process is not so easy because
there are many roadblocks in in the in
the path right there are several
nucleosomes
now let's see what are the difficulties
of a transcription Factor getting
recruited into the promoter let's say
these are some promoted region of a
particular Gene in red and the yellow
depicts that Gene body
so obviously we are now looking at and
appreciating a nucleosome Centric view
in a eukaryote
so the RNA polymerase and the
transcription Factor first need to get
recruited into the promoter now if DNA
is tightly wrapped around the
nucleosome core then it is difficult for
the transcription factor to get
recruited right so accessibility is a
big issue in this case
question is how this problem is solved
then
so many of the cases what happens is
transcription factors interacts with
complexes known as nucleosome remodeling
complex which kind of act on the DNA and
the histone to modify the interactions
between them in this case the nucleosome
remodeling complex has modified it such
a way that there is Now accessibility
and the transcription Factor can bind to
that
so transcription Factor can one side
interact with nucleosome remodeling
complex but also specialized
transcription Factor can interact with
enzymes like histone acetyl transferase
which can modify histones his Stone
acetyl transference can put histone
acetyl marks on specific histones and as
a consequence of that
there would be now change in the
chromatin architecture the chromatin
would be more accessible because DNA
would be Loosely packing
the nucleosome there is a lot more
accessibility transcription factors can
access the promoter region even it can
recruit polymerase and polymerase would
find it easier to move along the gene
body
so transcription Factor can interact
with many partners and that give rise to
the effect
on transcription for example if
transcription factors interact with
co-activator complex it results in
transcription activation it can in a
context dependent fashion interact with
co-repressor complex which might lead to
transcription repression it can interact
with histone acetyl transfer is which
leads to acetylation of specific
histones in along the gene body in the
nucleosomes which are situated on the
gene body
this would increase the accessibility
increase the chance of transcription
also there could be interaction with DNA
sorry in interaction with histone
deacetylases which deacetylate
particular nucleosomes and lead to a
chromatin compaction this would lead to
a inhibition of transcription
also nucleosome remodeling complex
can interact with the overall chromatin
in several ways transcription Factor can
work hand in hand with these nucleosome
remodeling complex leading to
replacement of specific histones
sliding off specific nucleosome freeing
up new spaces and also eviction of a
histone so kicking out his Stone from
its own way and making the road free for
transcription factors or let's say RNA
polymerase
so this is how possibly transcription
Factor along with its partner can have
effect on the transcription
now transcription Factor has a peculiar
feature that they mostly have a DNA
binding domain
and this DNA binding domain interacts
with mostly the major groove of the DNA
there are a few active exceptions but
many of these transcription factors are
interacting with the bases in the
major Groove such as we can take the
example of Helix Loop Helix family
where the helixes are kind of inserted
into the major Groove we can take
example of leucine zipper motifs
losing zipper motifs are also helic
Alpha helical structures inserted into
the grooves and also helicorn Helix that
are sitting on the DNA in the major
group region so major groove of the DNA
is a key site of interaction for many
transcription factors there are several
transcription factors which has beta uh
plated sheet in their in their DNA
binding domain and few of the
interactions also happen in minor group
but in most of the cases it's a major
group of the DNA which is targeted
now transcription Factor could be very
important from a cell fit specification
point of view let's say this cell can
either have a epithelial Fit versus a
neuronal fit
question is how this fate is chosen
there are external and internal factors
that can trigger
specific Master regulator transcription
factor which might lead to acquisition
of one fate
this kind of regime is followed in the
immune system let me give you a real
example
so in the immune system there is CD4
positive T helper cells which can
ultimately give rise to several
different subtypes of T helper cells
like th1 th17 follicular T cells th2
cells Etc but question is how to create
these different kind of cells from one
common progenitor type cell
so external influence such as
interferons or let's say cytokines
triggered the activation of Master
transcription factors in the cd8 force T
cell and depending on which Master
transcription factor is triggered it
would trigger a different gene
expression module or it would activate a
specific module which is exclusive to
our cell
and that would lead to specific terminal
Fates so these kind of operational
regimes are true for many biological
systems and it is true for development
as well
in development transcription Factor can
work in various different way generally
transcription factor is triggered by a
specific morphogen exposure so
morphogens ultimately lead to signaling
Pathways that activate specific
transcription factors there are Auto
regulatory feed forward Loop for example
a morphogen or a signal
leads to activation of a transcription
factor and later on this transcription
Factor produce itself creating a Auto
for feed forward Loop this kind of
transcription example of this kind of
transcription factor is PAX 3 which is
responsive to the morphogen wind and it
is found in neural tube development
also there could be Cascade of feed
forward Loop in this case product of
each step is helping in the uh forward
step so that means a transcriptional
factor Cascade is regulating a gene
network loop
also there could be mutual repression
one transcription factor is inhibiting
the production of other transcription
factor and this kind of mutual Loop can
create sharp tissue boundaries
also there could be complicated
transcription Factor networks and in
development for several uh particular
organs these kind of transcription
Factor networks are really important
there could be mutual repression there
could be feed forward activity feedback
activity so all of the possible
activities can be happening inside a
complicated Loop and these are really
important for self at specification
development and patterning
so I hope this was useful if you if you
like this video give it a quick thumbs
up don't forget to like share and
subscribe you can follow us on Instagram
or Facebook
you can support our Channel via super
thanks you can uh pay via paytm PayPal
or UPI see you in next video